in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion, for September 27th, on which we commemorate,
the Holy Martyr Calistratos, and the Holy 49 Martyrs with him.
On the 27th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Calistratos
and of his 49 companions.
Saint Calistratos lived in the reign of Diocletian in the years 284 through 305.
He came from Carthage, of a family Christian, since the time of Christ,
when one of his ancestors saw with his own eyes the miracles the Lord brought
and converted his relatives on returning to his homeland.
Calistratos was serving with a legion called the Kalindal that was on its way to Rome.
Some of his fellow soldiers noticed that Calistratos avoided the disillute behavior
common in military life and gave the idols no worship.
They decided to watch him carefully and in the evening when he left the camp
as usual to pray undisturbed.
They followed him and listened as he continued for many hours to repeat the blessed name
of our Lord Jesus Christ.
They denounced him to their commanding officer who had him report next day at dawn
for questioning about his conduct.
The valiant Calistratos who had confessed Christ hitherto only in the dark
and lonely watches of the night now confessed him publicly in the light of day.
Presentinos had him stretched on the ground and savagely beaten.
They pushed a funnel into his mouth and forced him to swallow a basin full of water.
After that he was tied up in a sack and thrown into the sea.
But God saw to it that the sack split and two dolphins brought him back to the shore.
When they saw this miracle, the 49 soldiers standing there repented of having handed over Calistratos
and believed in Christ.
They in their turn were put to the torture and thrown into prison
where Calistratos instructed them in the holy doctrines concerning the coming of Christ in the flesh.
The last judgment and the reward promised to faithful soldiers of Christ.
The next day they were tortured again, bound hand and foot and thrown into a deep swimming pool.
Calistratos prayed that this bath might become for them the labor of holy baptism.
As soon as they were cast into the water, their bonds loosened and they emerged clothed in shining raiment
while a crown appeared on Calistratos' head and a heavenly voice was heard encouraging him and his companions
to hasten to the eternal habitations prepared for them.
At the sound of this voice a nearby idol fell to the ground, reduced to ashes,
which led to the conversion of a further 135 soldiers.
For fear of other miracles and more conversions, presentinos had the saints cut to pieces
that very night in their prison.
The 135 new converts devoutly buried their remains and built a church in their honor at that place
through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.